Okay, looks like users are making
accounts on our backends, so
that's cool.
But, none of them can actually login.
Before my roommates start a riot,
let's add some login functionality.
Here's a quick overview of what happens
behind the scenes when you login with
Firebase.
In the code for your app,
you'll call authWithPassword().
This sends a message to your
online Firebase database to try to
authenticate the user.
The online Firebase database has
a hidden credential data store,
which includes hashes of emails and
passwords of users that have
been created in your Firebase.
Firebase is doing the hard work of
actually checking the credentials.
And if successful, it creates something
called an AuthData object and
adjacent web token.
This adjacent web token,
also called a JWT,
is a token that is automatically
stored for you by the Firebase SDK.
It gets stored in local storage for
you app, and
this arrives between
between app reloads.
It's this token that allows your user to
stay logged in even if they close and
then reopen the app.
Then again, this part is
automatically taken care of for you.
So you don't really need to worry about
JWTs or doing anything with them.
The AuthData object,
on the other hand, is something that's
explicitly returned to your code.
And it's an object that contains
basic data about the user.
So then when you get the AuthData
object back in your app,
you can use this data to update your UI.
As a developer, from your vantage point,
all you really have to do is call this
method here and
then get a AuthData object back.
The rest of this is handled by Firebase.